así se ven las oficinas de la
cancillería de Haití los haitianos
acuden en masa para solicitar un
pasaporte es uno de los requisitos para
llegar a Estados Unidos sueñan con una
nueva vida
voy a probar suerte como los demás
Porque si ellos tienen una oportunidad
yo también tengo familia en los Estados
Unidos
vivo en un país que no funciona donde no
se respeta la gente y no se valora a los
jóvenes pero no traicionaría a mi patria
Siempre será haitiano Y eso no cambia mi
forma de ver el mundo pero siendo joven
Necesito un futuro
el 8 de enero el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden anunció un nuevo plan
migratorio Este ha sido ratificado en la
Cumbre de Los tres amigos con sus socios
de México y Canadá cada mes podrán
entrar al país 30.000 personas de Cuba
Haití Nicaragua y Venezuela tendrán que
llegar por avión ser patrocinados por un
estadounidense y demostrar ingresos
suficientes estamos intentando facilitar
la llegada de la gente abriendo la
capacidad de llegar aquí pero sin que
tengan que pasar por ese camino
espantoso vamos a seguir esforzándonos
por abordar las causas profundas de la
migración para ayudar a la gente a
permanecer en sus países de origen los
haitianos una de las nacionalidades
beneficiadas huyen de una crisis
multifactorial que persiste a pesar de
los años Haití ha llegado incluso a
tener al menos 450 muertos por cólera
enfermedad erradicada en gran parte del
mundo Mientras que el control
territorial ha quedado en grandes partes
del país en manos de pandillas